to travel by canoes to ponder where we  came from where we are where we're going  who we were who we are and who we can be  suspended between the world above and  the world below stillness in harmonic  motion these are the paddles promises  the paddle is to plug into the energies  of the place the land the air the water  the ancestors the children who are yet  to be born the paddle connects us to all  of that to pole is to connect to the  river itself but also to the lands at  nourishes to be there to be connected as  a mix of Canadians new and old if it is  love that binds people to places in this  nation of rivers and in this river of  nations then one enduring expression of  that simple truth is surely the commune  [Music]  [Music]